what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay we've talked about some powerful
mutants right like Matthew Malloy
all right Matthew Malloy what in our
discussions about powerful mutants all
right Matthew Malloy was like okay the
most powerful mutant that we'd ever
talked about on my channel I mean there
was like Franklin Richards and Matt Jim
Jasper's and there were some crazy
powerful mutants man let me tell you
something dude this guy the marquee of
death
there's beyond omega-level mutant and
like then there's this guy I mean this
dude it's stupid how powerful this guy
is and that's a crazy thing I'd never
heard of him until like three or four
days ago and like somebody commented in
one of my videos and they were like hey
would you do something about the marquee
of death and I'm like what the hell's
the marquee of death and so like I just
started poking around online and I was
like Jesus this guy alright so here's
the deal here's the marquee of death is
a dude named Clyde winch him junior and
his whole origin actually came out of a
2008 story called Marvel 1985 now here's
the deal
for those of you guys who were new to
Marvel Comics there's what's called
original graphic novels original graphic
novels are basically just stories in
comic books and they don't have any one
particular place that they fit into it's
just a story out there somewhere The
Dark Knight Returns is an example of an
original graphic novel it's just a story
that takes place somewhere along the
line but it doesn't really fit into any
existing continuity Marvel 1985 was an
original graphic novel in so much that
it was six parts but it might as well
have just been in original graphic novel
I mean they release it as a singular
trade or something like that but it's
basically just a story that just kind of
takes place out there in the middle of
nowhere
and there's no actual timeline that's
specified to it which means that like
none of the Marvel characters reference
it later on so it's just kind of out in
the middle of no man's land but the fact
remains Marvel 1985 is a story that's
largely told from the perspective of a
kid named Toby and Toby is this kid
who's just kind of hanging out and so
the whole story takes place in earth
1218 which is them like the real world
that's the world that we're in right now
where you're watching this video and I'm
making this video and all that kind of
good stuff the whole idea is that Toby's
just this kid who's like hanging out and
there's this place called the wind chim
house and the idea is that no one goes
to the wind gym house it's like it's
considered to be haunted / cursed /
nobody goes there you know Toby's dad
Jerry is like don't go there you know
stay away from the winch um house will
eventually Toby goes by there one day
and sees like the Red Skull and he's
like what in the heck because in the
real world he reads comic books it's
always like the Red Skull is a fictional
comic book character this is weird and
so as more time progresses these
villains from the Marvel Universe start
cropping up it's like vulture and it's
like you know Doctor Doom and so on and
so forth and so the whole idea is that
it leads to Tobey kind of trying to
figure out what's going on
but eventually Tobey discovers this
portal because by this point in the
story by the time you know Tobey
discovers this this portal things have
gone awry like Galactus has shown up in
the real world and it's gonna like
consume the earth so it's just like okay
we've got to do something
so Tobey finds this dimensional portal
he walks through and ends up in the
Marvel Universe in the main Marvel
Universe and then he goes to see the
Avengers and he gets run off they're
like whatever get out of here so he goes
to see the Fantastic Four and it's like
wait in line because there's a ton of
people waiting on the Fantastic Four so
eventually he discovers spider-man and
and it's really kind of cool because as
a person who read spider-man comics in
the real world
Tobey knows everything about Peter
Parker and so he basically kind of you
know confronts Peter Parker says hey
look I know everything about you and all
that kind of good stuff and then we
don't really see what happens instead we
end up picking back up back in the real
world and we actually end up joining up
with with Jeri and what we find out is
that when Jerry was a little kid he was
friends with this kid named Clyde and
the idea was that some were along the
line and no one really knows how but
somewhere along the line Clyde's house
just like vanished one day it was just
gone disappeared and then it reappeared
and there was no and no no indication
anybody knew what was going on there was
no indication that like Clyde or his mom
had any idea what happened or anything
along those lines and so you know Clyde
and Jerry continued to hang out and that
kind of thing we'll eventually what
happens is like one day everybody in
town just like goes into this hypnotic
state and they all just start descending
on the wind chim house well then like
Clyde wind chimes like deceased dad his
dead dad gets resurrected from the dead
and shows up on their front door and so
it's like what in the heck is going on
it saw like Hyde's mom starts freaking
out she starts blaming Jerry and then
Clyde speaks up he's like look I have
these powers to control reality but I
don't know how to use him his mom freaks
out hits him over the head with a
candlestick and sends him into a
catatonic state and so everything just
kind of goes back to normal
well then we fast-forward 20 years in
nineteen you know and in 2008 when the
story was written and we end up finding
out that Clyde was taken to an insane
asylum but when he was taken there he
wasn't
to bring his comics and so the result
was that you know he had basically
reached into the main Marvel Universe
and grabbed all these different villains
and then brought them over into the real
world and it was just designed for the
purpose of showing everybody like hey
you know you have to do what I tell you
to that kind of a thing this is the kind
of power I possessed so Jerry and his
guys you know end up grabbing the comic
books of Clyde and they end up bringing
them over at the same time Toby shows
back up with like the Avengers and the
Fantastic Four and the x-men like all
these different superheroes from the
main Marvel Universe and so it's like
this massive battle between like all the
villains and all the superheroes so
Jerry goes over to the insane asylum
where Clyde's at and it's like hey look
here's all your comic books I'm sorry
they took you you know took them away
from you here's your comic books back
and then Jerry please with Clyde to like
set things back to normal
well before or Clyde can do it the Red
Skull shows up and kills Jerry and so
Clyde's just like enough like he freaks
out like he's just like enough everybody
go back and he ends up like sending all
the supervillains back to the main
Marvel Universe well then Captain
America is like hey look man that was
kind of crazy you know look in my
universe we have people like you all
over the place that have like brain
damage and you know we have people like
Reed Richards and so on and so forth and
they can help you they can you know
return you to some state of normalcy now
that's where the story ends but if you
thought that was crazy
wait man man wait until you were getting
ready to get in to switch over to mark
Miller's Fantastic Four technically it's
issues 562 to 569 but really it's issues
564 to 569 and the reason why is because
of the fact that it's a story called the
master of doom or something along those
lines but the idea is that it picks up
in the end the point in the Fantastic
Four's history prior to Dark Reign when
dr. doom is basically arrested for all
the villainous hacks that he had ever
done and he was just put on trial for
crimes against humanity now being part
of Norman Osborn's whole whole cabal and
all I kind of get stuff he's basically
exonerated and allowed to go free and it
eventually goes back to Latveria but
when Reed Richards showed up to him and
said hey look man like I just want to
talk eventually you know doom kind of
plays some mind games whatever read
begins to walk off but then doom makes
reference to something about the master
that taught him everything and so that's
when it's just kind of like what like
what what in the world is going on and
it's really kind of weird because what
we end up doing is we actually jump
after the events of Dark Reign which I
think we covered during the Hickman's
Fantastic Four that's the point when
he's goes back to normal so to speak and
when doom is basically exonerate
that kind of a thing but from that point
going forward the story starts to pick
up with like these weird little things
that crop up here and they're like uh
there's this body of the watcher of who
ought to the watcher that just like
shows up on the ocean and it's too you
know detected by some scientist or
something like that Reed Richards goes
to figure it out you know goes to look
at it see what's going on whatever and
then doom goes back to Liberia well when
he gets there we end up finding out the
reason why he's throwing this huge
celebration is because his masters
returning and the idea is that when his
masters returning things are getting
ready to pop off where there were a
whole bunch of plot threads the Mark
Miller was writing at the time but once
we get back to the whole idea of like
the watch here we end up finding out
that it's not the main who watches The
Watcher from the main Marvel Universe
it's a version of who watches the
watcher from a different universe from
that point we pick up with with the
marquee of death
now the marquee of death just has like
this apprentice that's it that's all we
know it's just like an apprentice that
he has but the marquee of death is in
like this alternate universe all right
this guy shows up and we all have is off
the handle we don't actually see it but
this guy shows up and just like Oh
radically heroes I mean that's it like
like there's no contest like they're all
just dead they're all just killed off
well in this universe it was Reed
Richards and a guy named Jack Storm who
became the Human Torch and they actually
ended up getting in a relationship
together ended up getting married I
think but the crazy thing was that like
Reed Richards is the one person spared
alive well of course Jack Storm shows up
you know and as the Human Torch tries to
fight back and like the marquee of death
just like snaps his neck just like
reaches out into the sky and just snaps
his neck I promise it gets absolutely
bananas you know from this point going
forward so Reed Richards this alternate
reality version of Reed Richards kind of
begs and pleads whatever the marquee of
death doesn't care kills that version of
Reed by ripping his heart out and then
eating it and then he just sticks his
hand in the air he forces the Sun to go
supernova and then sets off a chain
reaction that ignites all the other
stars across the cosmos and then just
obliterates the universe in his entirety
not only that we end up finding out once
he shows up in the main Marvel Universe
with his apprentice and meets Doctor
Doom we end up finding out that what the
marquee of death and his apprentice had
been doing was just like hopping and
skipping from one universe to the next
just obliterating all the cosmic
entities like wiping out Galactus
eternity infinity mistress death just
like killing them all off and then just
like you know destroying all these
different earths and so on and so forth
so when the marquee of death finally
shows up to me Doctor Doom
this is the craziest thing about this
when he shows up to meet doom dooms
initial response is all right are you
happy with what I've done so far the
power that I've gained is so on and so
forth and in the marquee of death is
like no you're a colossal failure like I
literally showed up 20 years ago and
taught you everything that you knew
about like magic and mysticism I gave
you all the tools that you needed to
make yourself God and you've been
routinely defeated by the Fantastic Four
and so the result is that the marquee of
death like sets them on fire and tries
to kill them now the cool thing about
this is it like doom fights back my doom
ends up you know just kind of like
flipping out you know losing his mind
and attacking the marquee of death and
so it leads to like this six week long
battle like this six week long conflict
that stretches on and on and on
initially it was just dr. doom in the
marquee of death and then it's all the
other superheroes across the earth that
end up joining in so the x-men the
Fantastic Four Excalibur all these
different superheroes ended up joining
and even some super villains to join the
side of a Doctor Doom and trying to
defeat the Marquee of death so the
marquee of death is defeated Reed
Richards sacrifices his life dr. doom
marry Susan storm and then like they're
expecting a kid and so what we found out
was that the apprentice and the marquee
of death were defeated by Doctor Doom
when he locked him away and something
called the Omega box now we're not
really given any information on what the
Omega box is is just this box that's
designed to contain them but it says
really cool moment because it's like
under dr. doom the world had experienced
this whole new era of peace and
prosperity and all that kind of stuff
and it was just like this great
scientific age well Susan storm is just
kind of like hey are you finally happy
and dooms like yes and then she reveals
herself to be The Apprentice and like
the marquee of death steps out of the
Omega box not only that we end up
finding out that this was this was not
like some six week long battle it's been
less than five seconds all right not
only that alright this is this is where
it gets crazy
the marquee of death RA not only do t
like distort reality and screw up dr.
Doom's mind to make him believe six
weeks had passed all right he grabs dr.
doom he turns his heart to stone turns
his blood to acid opens up a time portal
and throws him 65 million years into the
past I've never seen anything like that
before the only time I ever saw anything
like that was during during the Infinity
Gauntlet story and that was
wielding the Infinity stones so the
marquee of death is like okay look like
if dr. doom was not able to beat the
Fantastic Four then I'm gonna be the one
to defeat them and then I'm gonna kill
him because I mean he had a thing about
it from his perspective right like he's
been traveling around these different
universes killing all these different
superheroes for him it's nothing to kill
the Fantastic Four
so the marquee of deaths first stop is
to basically meet and like torment and
torture Ben Grimm and so when he shows
up he basically makes Ben Grimm
witnessed the death of his Aunt Petunia
not only that he also turns around to
the other Fantastic Four and basically
says I killed Victor Von Doom I threw
him into the past
I turned his blood to acid turned his
heart to stone all that kind of good
stuff and when the Fantastic Four try to
fight back he just starts like
manipulating reality around them like he
basically turns Susan storms her force
fields and so on and so forth turns him
against her so it basically just kind of
shuts her down and almost puts her in a
catatonic state
he makes Johnny Storm witnessed all the
different times that the marquee of
death has killed Susan storm I mean it's
just it's absolutely bonkers because
he's just distorting reality in this
extreme way so eventually he grabs Reed
Richards and just like takes off like
he's he'd literally grab some and just
whisks him away to the other side of the
universe and then they start reality
hopping the first thing he does is he
takes him back to his own past he takes
him to the point when the Fantastic Four
first gained their powers and says look
I will go ahead and I will leave your
universe alone and I'll stop wiping out
all these different universes if you
kill Ben Grimm
because Ben Grimm wishes he could die
instead of becoming the thing he wishes
he could be dead you know and Reed
ultimately says no I'm not going to do
that he's better off alive and he is
dead so on and so forth and so then he's
like okay well what about your son
Franklin Richards he's got these godlike
powers he doesn't know how to control
them so on and so forth you know I'll
kill him and you know I'll go ahead and
kill him for you and again I'll spare
you know the multiverse basically Reed
again turns them down and so finally we
get this origin story for the marquee of
death and what this does is it picks up
after the Marvel 1985 story and what we
find out is that this new version of
Clyde Wyndham had basically been put in
a machine by Reed Richards that was
designed to prove to keep him in a state
of suspended animation to keep him in a
catatonic state but he would experience
nothing but like these incredible dreams
and so on and so forth well various
villains again this is an alternate
reality but various villains had shown
up like all of Reed Richards villains
had shown up and attacked Clyde winch
him
well then Claude winch
emerged from this containment unit or
whatever you want to call it and then
like had total control of his faculties
the dude waved his hand and all the
villains were dead just like waved his
hand I mean it wasn't like some
grandiose conflict or battle he was just
he just waved his ham and they all died
the molecule the molecule man Owen Reese
was just one of the people who were
killed by the Marquis of Death that's
how powerful this guy is the molecule
man Owen Reese is a guy that can
manipulate matter on a multiversal scale
he's a multiversal threat before his
powers were reduced he was more powerful
than the Living Tribunal that's how
powerful the molecule man Owen Reese was
the marquee of death just waved his hand
and the molecule man is dead now it does
beg questions was this molecule man
where's those powers unlocked was he as
powerful as his main earth-616 self we
don't know we were not given an answer
to that question but you know the
marquee of death says look this is me in
the past you could kill this version of
me and that will never become Who I am
right now but ultimately Reed says no
I'm not going to do that well we end up
finding out that all these different
alternate reality versions of mr.
fantastic that is to say the member of
the Fantastic Four who could stretch
we're all told by the marquee of death
I'm destroying your realities because
there will come a point when I will ask
Reed Richards from the main Marvel
Universe if he would kill his son or his
friend or even me at a younger state in
order to spare all your universes and
he's going to say no ie Reed Richards is
the reason why all their universes were
obliterated or why all the superheroes
on their earths were destroyed and so
the result is that Reed Richards ends up
having like the Fantastic Four have to
go against all these alternate reality
versions of Reed Richards like you know
whether it's Ben Grimm who becomes mr.
fantastic or Johnny Storm who becomes
mr. fantastic or Susan storm who becomes
mrs. fantastic whatever you know they
all end up descending on the Baxter
building for the purpose of just
unleashing absolute hell well then Ben
Grimm starts to overhear what it is
that's going on in the middle of this
whole conflict and realizes that this is
basically Clyde winch um from you know
area 87 you know the place that Reed
Richards had previously visited where he
kept Claude windchimes head in this
state of suspended animation while Ben
Grimm races off and grabs Clyde winch
him and brings him back now
this past version of Clyde winch am is
nowhere near as powerful as the marquee
of death but he's powerful enough that
when the two of them end up doing battle
it weakens the marquee of death but
notice
alright notice this when the two of them
are having their conversation and the
marquee of death is talking about all
the things that he's done he talks about
creating these constructs that were just
more powerful than Galactus imagine that
like a being so powerful that they just
created constructs that were more
powerful than Galactus and it made
Galactus look like absolutely nothing I
mean it's crazy the kind of things that
he could do and so the the marquee of
death starts talking about how he was
going through and just obliterating all
the cosmic entities that there was
child's play and so the result is that
when the two of them end up going into
battle with one another while the
marquee of death isn't really killed by
Clyde wind chime the result is that you
know the marquee of death is just
severely weakened by the attack and so
the result is that we end up learning
that The Apprentice that the marquee of
death has been walking around the
walking around with the entire time is
Doctor Doom and it's crazy because what
we end up finding out is that when
Doctor Doom was thrown into the past
where he was torn apart by all these
different you know dinosaurs and so on
and so forth these sharks that he used
magic to basically either regrow his
limbs or at the very least to keep
himself alive and then from there he
spent the next however many millions of
years just like walking the earth and
learning all these different forms of
magic now the death of this alternate
reality version of The Watcher was the
result of the fact that that watcher saw
what was going on with dr. Doom's the
dr. doom just killed him so he wouldn't
have to worry about it but then the
marquee of death encountered this guy
somewhere along the line but by that
point dr. doom had basically changed his
appearance in such an extreme way even
down to the molecular level the marquee
of death didn't realize it was dr. doom
and so the result was that the marquee
of death was walking around with the
very man that he would kill later on in
the future without ever having realized
it and so dr. doom basically overpowers
the marquee of death who's extremely
weak at this point totally incinerates
him and then just tells the Fantastic
Four I'm going back to Liberia
if you end up starting stuff I'm going
to obliterate all of you so again it's a
pretty quick ending to the story I mean
it's really the only way you can and I
mean what you're talking about a
character with power that extreme
there's only so much you can do but this
guy so this begs the question how
powerful is the marquee of death in
relation to other characters that we've
talked about what we know just by virtue
of his actions and going through and
killing the cosmic entities the marquee
of death is more powerful than the
molecule man Owen Ricci is more powerful
than the Beyonder because the Beyonder
is just as powerful as a molecule man
Owen Reese the marquee of death is more
powerful than Franklin Richards the
marquee
death is more powerful than Matthew
Malloy I would go as far as to say the
marquee of death might even be more
powerful than the Living Tribunal now
that makes the question why didn't the
Living Tribunal intervene no idea
probably just for the sake of the story
and it would have been easier just to
not have him in there maybe Mark Miller
forgot about him I have no idea but
given everything that we've seen in
terms of the power that the Marquis of
Death is displayed just kind of walking
around space and time and so on and so
forth the idea that after he had killed
all the supervillains he spent a billion
years learning how to manipulate all
space and time and controls
reality-warping powers I would say the
marquee of death is probably more
powerful than the Living Tribunal but
less powerful than the one above all so
it may very well be that the marquee of
death is the most powerful being in the
multiverse or at least was before he
died second only to you know the one
above all itself I mean that's that's
the only way I don't had a class I can't
I can't classify power like this I can't
explain power like this I had to read
this comic three times in order to be
able to grasp what it was that I was
seeing it's crazy this kind of thing is
absolutely bananas but this guy is so
wildly powerful it's the most powerful
mutant that I think has ever existed in
the history of Marvel Comics even adult
Franklin Richards that made Galactus is
Herald he was nowhere near that level I
mean as powerful as he was making
Galactus his Herald you know he still
wasn't able to defeat these Celestials
by himself so it means that he was on
par with Celestials but this guy the
marquee of death was way beyond the
Celestials way beyond the cosmic
entities I mean it's just it's it's it's
nuts it's bonkers it's one of the
craziest things ever so yeah as far as
I'm aware unless we end up discovering
something new this guy the marquee of
death is definitively the most powerful
mutant that's ever existed in the
history of Marvel Comics it's crazy
anyway guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explain make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob Court if you guys enjoy
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]